I'm Soulja Boy and one of my favorite
movies is Pursuit of Happyness
sooner happiness is definitely one of
their like top movies in my life that
changed my perception of the world and
how we view things and as I got older my
perception change when I first saw it I
understood it but I kind of didn't know
you know like what he was trying to do
you just think that you know you don't
know you you actually don't know that
he's homeless
when you younger you just kind of look
at the world as a free place you and you
using the same image imagination as his
son as a kid but as you get older you
understand on multiple levels of what's
going on so like you watch that movie
and you see Will Smith and you see Jaden
Smith in the bathroom with his foot on
the door and you know you go through
that what if I was in that position it
expands your mind it just makes you
appreciate life more and it makes you
think about everything that your parents
told you you'll probably be about as
good as I was that's kind of the way it
works you know and I was below average
he didn't realize what he was doing
which he was tearing his son's dreams
down and I feel like that was one of the
most important parts to the movie
because when I was a kid I you know I
had dreams of being a musician or you
know being a rapper and there were
channels delight you know being in high
school and you know even by my parents
there was like yo you know why why are
you in the computer so much and then
like once I explained to my parents like
yo like I really think I could do
something with music you know my mom was
confused she was like I know I don't get
it so like after later once I started to
reach my goal they started to understand
I definitely think making music is like
making a movie because some songs have
storytelling in it so you're telling
their story on us on and so on so when
you when you create in a movie it's the
same thing you have to tell a story you
have to have a beginning
in don't ever let somebody tell you you
can't do something so I definitely think
me sitting back and watching movies is
definitely made me believe I could reach
my goal it just show everybody out there
to never give up on your dream that's
one of those movies where I could see I
could watch the anytime
my name is Soulja Boy and I love movies